and I said hey unless you're out in the
bout with the goddamn Dave Matthews Band
you better get your ass home cuz shits
about to go down at morn paws
welcome to this is not happening
but I'm your host Roy Wood jr. hey there
you go boys drink up nobody's gonna
remember what the hell's happenin
tonight that dudes trying to get my
couch pregnant being out the window man
John Legend bought me that piano not a
ball pit
[Applause]
you know for the one-hour special on
wheels ugly and angry drip water
everybody
put my dad through a lot of and
this story is about that I never put him
through much as a kid but as an adult
when I come home where I haven't lived
for 12 years it's a bit of an event and
we like to party and sometimes my dad
gets caught up in the crossfire through
a bunch of weird experiences I become
friends with justin verlander who's a
pitcher for the Detroit Tigers yeah he's
not he's not here the Tigers were in
town playing the Royals and they had a
night off so Justin and I went out for
some drinks while we were out he said
hey man I think I know that girl over
there I think she's an actress I'm
pretty sure my girlfriend and I saw her
in a movie last month I should go get my
picture taken with her sent it to my
girlfriend I said hey man we're in
Kansas City no way that chick's
an actress
he said nah man he calls the waiter over
he said who's the chick over there he
goes man I don't know who the chick is
but everyone at that tables with Mumford
& Sons they're here
playing the arena tomorrow night and
they're here having dinner Justin says
send them a bottle on us meaning him
right I'm not paying for that okay
hey
not a huge lumford and Suns fan me when
I hang out with super-rich people I
don't pay for okay sorry
you fly private your bond was right
if he pays from a it doesn't even
show up on his register if I pay for my
I can't buy shoes next month and
I'm gonna be pissed so he sends them a
bottle they come over to say thank you
turns out it's not Mumford & Sons it's
just and Sons all right I don't know
where Mumford was but he wasn't there I
assumed he was back at the hotel writing
a song that at some point goes huh so
and Sons come over start talking to the
Detroit Tigers I'm not really involved
so I kind of tune it out when I come
back into focus ampersand sons are
talking to the Detroit Tigers about
beer pong like they're like hey we'll
whoop your ass at some beer pong and the
Detroit Tigers are like we get paid very
handsomely to put balls places
could bring it so I said hey fellas
my parents live about eight minutes from
here we could settle this and I said
that because I know full well that both
and sons and the Detroit Tigers have a
complete for at both of their hotels
where they can do whatever the they
want to do so there's no reason to come
to my parents house it was complete fake
hospitality until they turned around and
said yeah let's go to your parents
house and play beer pong it's
1:30 on a Sunday night
technically Monday morning my parents
aren't gypsies all right they got real
jobs with real responsibilities that
start in about four hours but I also
can't look at these dudes and be like
you guys my parents
[Applause]
so I just said it let's roll the
dice see what happens so we start
leaving about the time we're heading out
my sister texts me and says hey a
mountain about if you get home before I
do will you walk my dog and I said hey
unless you're out and about with the
goddamn Dave Matthews Band you better
get your ass home
cuz shits about to go down at my paws
so we roll into my parents house like 12
deep and start throwing beer pong and
got weird like weirder than I've
already described like my sister who's
30 ended up in her prom dress I don't
know I don't know how that happened
god bless her for still being able to
fit in it but also the right so at
one point in the evening I decided I
needed to step out and smoke some weed
and Suns come with me but since it was
the middle of the season the Detroit
Tigers could not partake so they had to
pretend like it was the playoffs and
watch
[Applause]
so we come back in from smoking weed
my dad's downstairs and he's pissed
apparently while we were outside we got
a little loud woke and mom and dad up so
I walk inside dad's like the fuck's
going on
I said hey Dad that's and Sons of
Mumford and Sons and this is half the
Detroit Tigers bullpen and we're playing
beer pong and it was in this moment that
I realized that my dad was not
incredibly sure if he was actually awake
you got to look at from a dad's
point-of-view he walks downstairs in the
middle of the night
sees a bunch of weird dudes that he kind
of recognizes and my sister's in her
prom dress shit's weird dad's obviously
befuddled he's just is that
Justin Verlander yes sir it is and he
just went I whatever and he just went
back upstairs that was the last you saw
them whole next day I'm freaking out
he's at work
I obviously slept in my parents have
done a lot for me over time I can't be
up like this so I got to make
amends so I'm like I'm gonna take him
out to dinner I'm gonna buy him drinks
I'm gonna do goodbye but then dad walks
in the door like he's at the greatest
day of his goddamn life he walks like
what's up everybody how you doing how
you doing but you all right
I looked at I go the hell happened to
you today said I hated you this
morning I woke up on four hours sleep
and I cursed your name all the way to
work but then I got to work
we had our morning meeting and everyone
started asking me why I look so tired
and exhausted and I started bitching
about my kids bringing home Detroit
Tigers and Mumford & Sons and playing
beer pong all night
now I'm the coolest in the
whole you guys been a lot of fun
everybody